Danke, dass du Clicks bei der
Online-Talkshow mitmachst. Wie läuft
's? Ich habe ein wirklich gutes Gefühl. Ja, ich
suche immer noch nach Freiheit. Ich bin verrückt nach
dir und mache jeden Morgen den Limbo-Tanz
läuft großartig, ja, du bist ein
erstklassiger Schauspieler, du hast dr getan.  Jekyll
und Mr.  Hyde und Broadway großartig, aber du
machst so etwas wie
Partymusik. Ja, warum hast du dich entschieden,
solche Musik zu machen? Ich habe mich für diese Musik entschieden,
weil die Plattenfirma sagte, du
solltest nicht können
Sehr ähnlich wie
dieses Mal der eine Song, der
meine Geschichte erzählt, und ich mache einen Song mit meinen
Kindern und The Romantics wurde von
Frank Wildhorn gemacht,
der die ganze Musik für Jacqueline
Highs geschrieben hat, es ist wirklich ein ziemlich großer, sehr
klassischer Broadway, und sie sagten, oh  Nein,
nein, das ist Deutschland, er suchte nach
Freiheit, du musst denken, ich bin nicht verrückt,
Leute, riesig, und ich ging in Ordnung, und ich und ich
sagten, aber ich habe einen Song, den ich wirklich
machen möchte, und es ist ein wirklich gutes Gefühl,
und sie sagten, weil  So fühle ich
mich, also haben wir eine Rockversion davon gemacht
und wir sind gegangen und haben das Album aufgenommen,
weil wir dachten, ich weiß nicht, ob
irgendjemand Alben kauft, vielleicht werden sie
heruntergeladen, weißt du, gutes Gefühl, vielleicht
drei oder vier Songs herunterladen, aber  sie
sagten n  o es gibt immer noch Leute, die CDs kaufen,
also haben wir ein paar nette Balladen und
Schlager gemacht, ah, und da habe ich gesagt, lass es uns
ausprobieren,
und wir sind auf Tour gegangen, um die Musik auszuprobieren, um
zu sehen, ob sie funktioniert, und sie war ziemlich
erfolgreich, also tue ich es.  Ich weiß nicht, ob wir
irgendwelche Platten verkaufen werden, es ist nur
eine Art Weg, um
wieder auf den deutschen Markt zu kommen, damit ich
auf Tour gehen kann, und bis jetzt scheint es
ziemlich gut zu laufen,
also ist es für dich nicht so  wichtig, wenn
es qualitativ hochwertige Musik ist, was dieser Erfolg ist,
es ist wichtiger, diesen Spaß zu haben,
ja, und wenn du zu meinem Konzert kommst, wenn
du bei meinem Konzert warst, wirst du
zweieinhalb Stunden verrückten Spaßes sehen, ich meine
verrückt  Spaß, ja, Sie haben Typen, die sich
wie ich verkleidet haben, verrückt sind, Sie haben Leute, die
zu viel trinken, und dann haben Sie
Leute, die so sind wie David
Hasselhoff und kleine Kinder und
Großmütter, die gehen Ich habe nach
dir gesucht, ich meine, du weißt und dann das  Balladen
sind so, es ist ein gigantischer Querschnitt
von Leuten, also wenn ich das mache  Album,
es ist ein komisches Album, weil es so ziemlich
alles für jeden enthält, also
weiß ich nicht, was mein Publikum beim Kauf von
Platten ist, wirklich nicht. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob
es sich verkaufen wird oder nicht, und du
weißt, ich träume  Nachts auf meinem Kerlwort,
das Level 46 ist. Ich wache auf
und mache mir Sorgen, was mit mir nicht stimmt. Alles, was ich will, ist, die Leute wissen zu lassen, dass Rock'n'Roll und musikbewusste Tatl
für mich dasselbe sind. Es ist Unterhaltung,
wenn ich muss, wenn du  Bring mich zum
Titel der Musikkonferenz. Ich habe die Verantwortung
, die Leute zu unterhalten, die sie nicht bekommen.
Hey, wir wollen die Welt rocken, wenn ich in einen
Club gehe, werde ich den Rock singen und ich
werde den House-Mix bekommen und ich  Ich
werde es wirklich runter und schmutzig machen, weißt du, und
wenn ich an einen Ort gehe, wo es Kinder gibt,
wollen wir etwas für die Kinder tun, okay,
du hast gestern Abend verrückt
gesagt  David
Hasselhoff, er ist verrückt, stimmt,
du bist ein bisschen verrückt, die letzte Person, die
es mir gesagt hat  Ich war verrückt, war Russell
Brand okay, weil ich ein Interview
mit Russell Brand geführt habe und er sagte, du wärst
verrückt, und ich sagte, du sagst mir, ich bin
verrückt, du weißt, ich bin ziemlich normal,
ich bin nur verrückt in a  lustige Art, wie Sie wissen, ich
meine, ich bin keine verrückte Party oder ich bin ein
verrückter Mann, ich bin ein
Ich bin ein Vater, den ich gerne mache - ich liebe es, auf die Bühne zu gehen
und auf Bühnen verrückt zu werden, es macht
wirklich am meisten Spaß  habe wirklich
performt und der Rest des Reisens
und es ist wie hier auf der Hamburg. Ich war
noch nicht einmal draußen, weißt du, ich
möchte über das Atlantic Hotel gehen und
sagen, oh Mann, oh du kennst ihn, ja, sicher,
ja, jeder Matthews Ryan, der -
Lindenberg, du weißt, für wen die Organe ich
weiß, dass ich
seit 1989 da bin, also kennst du Peter bono. Ich kenne
all diese Typen, wenn ich Howard Karpin
de Lima sage, oh mein Gott, ich weiß sogar, dass die
Flossen noch leben, okay, du  bin ein
fan der deutschen musik ich sehe sie in
jeder show mann
yeah und dann komm ich vorbei hallo hallo
ihr wisst schon und es ist toll weil ich sie liebe  Ich
liebe Menschen, die ein langes Leben haben, denn
das ist für mich ein echter Star, die
Lindenberg absolut organisch
machen. Howard Coverdale. Es ist mir egal, ob Sie
ihre Musik mögen oder die Musik nicht
mögen  Wir sind 30, wenn du 20 Jahre in
diesem Geschäft durchhalten kannst, weißt du, das ist
verdammt unglaublich, okay, also, was ist das
Geheimnis dahinter, besonders das Geheimnis
deines Erfolgs in Deutschland, komm einfach immer
wieder wie Weihnachten. Ich komme jedes
Jahr zurück, also kommt Weihnachten hierher
Das Geheimnis ist, eine gute Zeit zu haben.
Das Geheimnis ist, hundert Prozent zu geben.
Du weißt, was alle zu mir sagen. Dein
Konzert war verrückt. Du bist eine
unglaubliche Figur
Ich will feiern, dass du weißt, dass ich jede Nacht, wenn ich von der
Bühne gehe, gehe. Ich kann das nicht mehr
auf der 58. tun, aber ich meine, ich kann
jeden überdauern, weil ich dieses Gefühl wirklich genieße,
ich meine und ich kann -
egal ob es zweitausend sind oder
zehntausend  Menschen Ich bin irgendwie
in eine Person versunken und ich kann auf
eine Person zoomen und diese Person beeinflussen und
sie sehen, ich schaue sie an und verstehe sie,
ich kann sie wirklich verstehen, und das ist
mir schon passiert, wenn ich ins Theater gehe, wenn
jemand zoom ist, dass ich auf mich gehe,
oh und ich bekomme, ich spüre dieses großartige Gefühl
und so unterhaltsam berührt die Menschen
auf emotionale Weise, ob es
sie zum Weinen bringt, sie zum Nachdenken bringt, sie
glücklich macht, ihnen klar macht, dass sie
dankbar sein sollten für das, was wir tun.  habe und auch, wenn
du das Fernsehen einschaltest und all
das Zeug siehst, das auf der Welt passiert,
und du siehst das Reality-Fernsehen,
das Müll ist und die Leute dazu bringt, dumme,
verdammte Dinge zu tun, und dann du, weil die
Leute wirklich ein gutes Herz haben und es
wollen  glücklich sein und sie wollen
positiv sein, weißt du, und das vergessen wir alle
, aber komm zu meinem Konzert, es
wird eine andere Sache sein, und das ist
irgendwie, dass ich diese Energie von den Leuten ziehe,
also wenn ich denke, was ich mag, fang an, das
Leben zu ernst zu nehmen  geh wow du weißt ich
denke an eis geh zur tür raus
hallo in den Maids hallo hallo hallo und
ich geh wie geil ist das ok also ich wünsche
dir ein richtig gutes gefühl vielen dank
ich bin verrückt nach dir
du